[Music]
we're going to show two games of acara
Nakamura okay and if you thought who's
evil wait so you see these games okay
now it's funny about Nakamura is he
would have won the London chess classic
if there were no Americans including
himself because he lost to both
Americans he did a reverse Levon Aronian
if you remember the sink filled Cup
Aronian want he beat only Americans but
he beat all of them and here Nakamura
actually got plus three against the non
Americans which is a big score
considering he's only playing seven
other people so three wins and four
draws is a reasonable result but then he
lost the two Americans just a second
while I cry okay hey get out of here you
alligator all right so yeah they didn't
get that you didn't need to get it
either at home alright so the first game
was from the first round as you all
remember Nakamura lost two so in the
Sinquefield Cup also now here's
something you didn't know actually you
used to know but you forgot that they
didn't forget or used to know it is that
the Sinquefield Cup in London chess
classic had the same pairings with
colors reversed so if you played
somebody in round one of the Sinquefield
cup you played them in round one of the
London chefs classic which is very
confusing for Michael Adams since he
didn't plan this thing feel Cup so he's
like wait a minute what do I do now he's
got to buy every round so it was still
the best score he ever had and they were
0.5 that's just showing you because he's
a British Grandmaster okay no I'm just
kidding Adams is one of the only good
British grandmasters ever okay anyway
back to what we were talking about what
we're talking about oh yeah Nakamura so
now so be Nakamura with the Catalan in
the Sinquefield Cup in London chest
classic Wesley had black and actually
this was an important match up because
these were the only two people who could
win the grand chest or you might be
thinking grand chest or who cares that's
correct
however there's lots of prize money okay
and Nakamura doesn't play for a prize
money he plays for some other reason
okay so yeah that was funny all right
so Wesley so was in clear first in the
grand chest or Nakamura was in clear
second the only way for Nakamura to win
the grand chest or was he had to come
and clear first and so would come in
fourth or worse okay and none of that
happened because of the first round so
Wesley had the black pieces and they
played a very interesting Grunfeld and
for some reason Hikaru doesn't do well
against the Grunfeld um I was working
with him in the 2011 tall memorial in
what city you Athens Wow worst answer
you've ever given you get extra credit
okay Riga was a reasonable answer but
still incorrect okay
and also Arjun has a question for you
where is Riga that's his question was
that your question Arjun what country is
Riga in what's that Greece so you said
Athens and now you're saying Riga Greece
you got taken to Greece the correct
answer is Moscow all right so this was a
grünfeld and against the Grunfeld in the
tall Memorial in 2011 which Chicago
faced twice he lost both games in fact
that tournament
hikaru lost three games with white and
drew all his games with black very
suspicious okay don't do that unless
you're playing me then alright okay so
here he plays a different way than he
played earlier in those games they play
sort of a normal kind of modern grünfeld
now for those of you at home then
Simon's just left
so my next 1,000 words will be okay but
I'll be talking about bridge all right
the fine-tooth comb look you all he's
coming back he heard me what not now
you're good bang good leave you can
leave okay so Bishop III and rook c1 is
very modern because you get your rook
off of this diagonal you're actually
supposed to learn chess in this class
horrible okay unlike the previous class
where do you go there you are hiding
yeah
okay very good and I've noted this in
many of my lectures modern chess is you
develop one side of
bored then you develop the other side of
the board later okay and they say more
if he wouldn't win any games today okay
here we get all of his pieces out
confusing his opponent all right but now
why can play moves like d5 and he's not
giving his Queen side away okay castles
Queen d2 e 5 e 5 is also a modern kind
of move we're putting white to the test
right now and I'm sure all of you will
give the obvious move that white played
d5 otherwise white Center sort of
crumbles and there's a movie you've
never seen before or heard of even
though I've told you about it called the
great chess movie so anybody's seen or
heard of that movie Wow nothing as per
usual okay at the raising their hand at
home but they're lying
like no no no I know you didn't see it
okay it was a documentary made around
1980 give or take some by 1980s Canadian
movie and it stars karpov course should
I Fisher Lubavitch Hort and many other
grandmasters and they talk about the
history of chess and chess players
nowadays although when I say nowadays I
mean the 70s okay and they interview a
lot of the best players in the world I
actually owned a copy but I'm not sure
where it is now probably I don't have it
anymore I've seen it many times and they
talk about hyper-modern chess which is
arjen's favorite right Arjun these would
say no you didn't read his lines didn't
bring me anything
no no holiday present no wedding present
nothing right okay as far as like
probably when this video comes I'm
already divorced I'm not even married
yet as far as you're concerned terrible
okay also this is in the future because
they're looking at 2017 and we're 2060
we're awesome okay they're 10 minutes
ahead of their time all right so in that
movie they talk about hyper modern chess
you give your opponent the center and
then you explode it and destroy it and
that's what Wesley is doing this game
although after d5 white still has a nice
Center ok Knight d7 C 4 and C 4 is
explosive
f-five Bishop g5 attacking the Queen
Knight f6 and now this was all played
relatively quickly and now Hikaru did
what I like to call a Kaden trophy and
if your Kaden trove I'm just kidding
okay okay one of Kayden's issues which
he's had more than once
is he says this is my prep I think this
is the move I prepped and then that's
nothing if he prepped okay and then he
loses he makes some of the losses again
okay and the karo does that right here
hakarl says oh yeah this is my prep yeah
and I prep the move 92 that's my prep
okay and this may have been his prep but
92 is nothing will be prepped okay and
the idea is he wants to play Knight c3
move his Bishop castle and his game is
great okay but a much better move would
be Bishop to d3 which stops Knight takes
e4 and the problem is after the very
simple calculation Knight e4 which was
played black is just winning and
something that's sort of hard to see it
was hard to see for me it looks like
it's possible this knight on D 2 gets
trapped but it never ever ever gets
trapped because it can always take this
bishop so there's that Knights not
getting trapped so there's basically no
calculation you take upon any up upon
now I was losing pawns before you were
born
including Claudio okay and you know
sometimes you lose a pawn
unfortunately White's development is
very suspicious and white just lost a
center a pawn if why did lost as a pawn
yeah okay then you're down upon when you
lose your center pawn that's not good
okay also black gets the two bishops
because in this position your bishops
are both hanging okay and Leslie so is
too good if a car was playing me he
probably wouldn't lose if he was playing
you at home you would have resigned by
now after after like now you'd see you
just resign
you'd be like wow that's good prep I
miss Knight takes e4 okay
here though black is just winning now
luckily for a car oh he can win his pawn
back but his game is just awful this
should be seven rook f7 and we get this
position so material is equal but White
has these weak pawns black has the two
bishops White's King is terrible White's
rook is terrible and black has this nice
Center and we get to attack right away
with b6 and Bishop a6 and we're just
going to play rook c8 and there's a lot
of good defenses to this pawn I just
don't see any okay this works going to
come here and you're going to be in
trouble and you're in trouble here and
you got the nice Center for black and
whites position is ridiculous the
computer says black is something like +2
and this is a one move blunder based on
the fact that he thought 92 is his prep
now there's another American you've
never heard of
Fabiana Cara Juana okay or as the answer
would say no that was even worse than
the answer that's very impressive no he
likes to say card you won I'm like card
you wanna he's like card you wanna and
then we got and fight okay then there's
a smoke break and then I take a nap and
that's that's what happens at me and yes
sir okay
and yes sir was staying in my house and
I kicked him out and I'm staying on his
floor something like that happened
that's about half true but half of what
I said was true he was staying there
he's not there now I'm there so there's
a lot of it's true okay now yeah
unfortunately this Bishop is not only
winning this pawn but there's some other
issues here okay and we can't really
play king d2 and get our rook somewhere
good because Bishop h6 is annoying so
all of whites pieces are bad and all of
his pawns are bad and black has the two
bishops okay now again if I was black
and probably a draw but Wesley so is
black that it's not good okay so f4 the
only way to activate the rook otherwise
the rook stays on f1 forever rook c8
takes and now in this position
sleep lay to move the computer didn't
like but it really didn't care very much
it's like this isn't the best move but
your work position so good it doesn't
matter okay he pinned his own bishop I
would never do that because I would be
afraid so I wouldn't do that just
because I'm afraid
Wesley calculates the million moves
ahead so he's not afraid although since
the bishop can't move right now the
computer prefers rook takes c4 and then
if there's a rook trade for example
Rick's e4 Bishop c4 you'll notice that
White has a lot of pawns hanging the a
to pawn the d5 pawn and blacks a pawn op
and Black has two bishops and this
plunge almost hanging okay although one
of the former American world champions
took that pawn and didn't like it and
they still didn't get it nothing
Bensimon got it no I'm kidding you to
get it what you never heard him okay
so White's pawns are all hanging and
he's down upon and black has the two
bishops so that was a better way of
playing but Bishop c4 doesn't spoil
anything
and generally Wesley so from the fine
gold school of chess doesn't want to
trade never trade the more pieces that
are on the board the less safe White's
King will feel it's an endgame but black
is full good attack against White's King
okay rook e3 attacking the bishop Bishop
g7 saving the bishop are you taking
notes on this Arjen attack the bishop
move the bishop away okay Knight f4 rook
to d7 a4 a4 is an important idea which I
teach all of my students and they don't
listen
now you could not listen right that'll
be awesome although you're listening a
little too much you're taking notes I
don't know about that that's too much
listening okay when you're losing and or
worse and you know it clap your hands
clap your hands argue okay so when
you're losing your down material your
game is not good you know you want to
trade all the pawns because your
opponent won't meet you with a bishop
well okay maybe Jason but if your
opponent has a king and a bishop and you
have a king and that's it you're not
going to lose but if your opponent has
pawns on the board
now you're going to lose White has an
isolated a plan he wants to trade off
give black an isolated pawn and if
there's no plums on the board you'll
have chances to draw
so this mastering the middle again the
middle games sort of over even though
white still got attacked at the endgame
this is like sort of half middle game
half endgame this is an endgame lecture
I could talk about this it's the middle
game I could talk about this oh Kobe
would be proud okay who wants to see it
again all right so yeah some people got
that okay probably not far all right
so in this position white has a big
issue which I fallen for twice in the
last three years that I know of I
probably fall in for ten more times than
I wasn't shown okay black has a bishop
like also another Bishop and for some
reason why put all of his pieces on the
same color so that sort of entices black
to attack all of White's pieces with one
move so that's a very risky thing to do
when your opponent has a bishop and you
put your pieces on the same color as the
bishop
you could get forked and skewered and
all kinds of things I'd never heard of
so that's very risky so Bishop h6
screaming out to be played and then
that's tough to defend all of that okay
white played the obvious move g3 I don't
think there's another move and then
Bishop takes pawn takes and White has a
fantastic pawn structure now I'm just
kidding now unfortunately this is not an
endgame lecture but I'll still yell at
you about the endgame especially true in
the middle game obviously color vicious
favor the attacker it doesn't look like
there's an attack here but actually
there is some but in the endgame
most people are like ooh obviously
colored bishops that's a draw when okay
if it's only bishops it's occasionally a
draw but when there's rooks on the board
opposite Clark Bishop doesn't matter
unless they're obviously colored rooks
which they are who these will hold on
he's taking notes
opposite color OPP that are you are you
done with OPP
very good that was the only good answer
if you were here for my previous lecture
did you record my lecture on macro valve
21st century on that you did you sure
yeah I showed a game where mock OVA have
had opposite colored bishops and then he
actually no no I don't think you
recorded this one because this wasn't a
mock ov a of it was just a game that he
played I think it was in the first
lecture you didn't record I think you
even like deleted you recorded just so
you could delete it I think that was
anyway there was an opposite Clark
Bishop ending with just an extra pawn
and no rooks and he won easily but he's
Michael Vale okay but I digress Reb
takes d5 how many pawns is black op
Arjen to and White has three isolated
pawns that's not good
okay now normally Nakamura is a great
fighter and he wins and draws positions
where he's worser losing or much worse
and when he does lose it takes 9,000
woozi never resigns that's the normal
nakamura this today's NACA more in this
game was like a Ben feingold nakamura
like terrible move resigned right away
okay so he played rookie 7 the pho
aggressive move and that's when Arjun is
always saying he's like what's all of
these fellow aggressive moves right
Arjun okay and now you can see the rook
is pretty active scary okay rub 2d for
defending the bishop again and
threatening the f4 pawn and Bishop d2 is
played and now a really nice move from
Wesley so King f8 and usually when your
opponent's rook is on the seventh rank
threatening a pawn you don't give up
another pawn and give them a choice
that's not what you usually do is it
okay and the idea is even though it's
the endgame black still has an attack on
White's King so if the rook takes either
pawn we play rookie for check and then
White has to cry because White has three
legal moves and they're all terrible
this should be three even you know is
terrible King
d1 allows Bishop b3 check and King f2
allows Ricky to check their for the rook
can't take either pawn Ricky for Czech
wins immediately but Nakamura wasn't
worried about King f8 because he just
went back to B for threatening double
discovered triple sideways check right
Arjen no is correct
okay let's discover check and
unfortunately the rook is threatening
discovered checks but Wesley so pinned
the rook that wasn't very nice
so the rook can go to all these squares
but it would be double check okay
because White's King would also be in
check confusing the people at home who
don't know the rules okay and the
computer won't let me do it if I put
both sides in check the computer just
puts the rug back argent with some crazy
comment that's right very good
did you triple check your answer good
answer
okay now the Nakamura I know would play
on two or three puns now and go over our
I think Nakamura was very upset because
not only did he blunder the opening for
getting his prep I don't think he saw
rookie aid I think he thought okay King
goes back to GA Bishop d2 and will
repeat and Wesley will try to win
another way but after rook e8 white has
to trade rooks and then it's hard to
defend the f4 pawn very hard okay now
one way to defend it let's say you play
double check and the one way to defend
your pawn is you would home anybody not
know you're wrong at home
Arjun Bishop d2 and you guys are like
this is an end game and you're moving
your arms back and forth like King Kong
but actually rookie 4 check and the
middle game attack pulls through White's
losing material his king is in trouble
King F to Ricky to check King D 1 Bishop
III check so we can't play Bishop d2 but
we have to play Bishop d2 because we
don't want to be done three pawns that's
not good right Arjun obviously color
bishops don't matter when you're down
three points okay so after rook e8
seeing nothing better than that he
resigned because he's losing his f4 pawn
so not knock him or his best game or was
it now I like making fun of Nakamura
because who doesn't
but unlike Wesley so Fabiano Cara wanna
Vladimir Kramnik and ahni's Giri who all
lost no games all of them undefeated
Nakamura had five decisive results in
his first seven games and probably
that's why your watch to the London
chess classic not to see 37 drawers like
Nakamura loses Nakamura wins Nakamura
loses Nakamura wins and he got a plus
score now I had to talk about Emery tape
because why not and we'd say it was a
very exciting player he wasn't
grandmaster strength but he thought he
was and that's all that matters
okay so if you would home think your
Grandmaster strength there you go yeah
there was a US Championship which had a
fighting prize award okay
and the fighting prize award was $5,000
and it was subjective okay I bribe three
of the judges but I think the other guy
bribed four of them so fighting chest
yeah so yeah Nakamura with all kinds of
decisive games yeah we're talking on
Emery tape okay
so Emily tape played but they had a
special rule that you're not going to
like nobody in this room was going to
like it was $5,000 fighting prize but
you couldn't get a - score okay they
were like you know you can't just lose
all your games on purpose get the
fighting prize anyway in round 1 Emery
Tate had white against vara Cobian and
he destroyed Varco being crushed him
okay and then he went on to win and lose
an alternate okay and then he lost one
in the middle where he didn't alternate
and he had nine decisive results of the
US Championship okay four wins and 5
losses was ineligible five wins and four
losses would have been eligible okay
that was like 2006 see at 2006 am i
right 2007 no six it was in San Diego
and/or La Jolla I think it was La Jolla
okay so Nakamura resigns very suspicious
okay now the next scheme is even better
because people with their engines they
were like oh this is happening and
that's happening and everything's
happening but none of that was
happening okay the nine or F did really
badly in this tournament white was
crushing the night off okay you guys are
making fun of the Berlin and rightfully
so
like moving on okay so they played the
night off
because Nakamura plays the night off if
you remember and you don't Nakamura
played the night off against Fabiano in
the US Championship that also didn't go
well for black it went really badly for
black okay and in this night ourf
white played the old move which used to
be the only move ever play but now
nobody plays it Bishop g5 okay now that
all playing the English attack Bishop e3
f3 Queen d2 etc okay but they're playing
in London so that was too obvious
these are g5 is the old move em instead
of playing the main main main main main
line in this position you could play
Bishop e7 or you could play the poisoned
pawn and the polo guy F ski in Queen b6
he played h6 and then he played Queen b6
so already I know nothing but the
players have hundreds of hours of prep
here comes the man from San Diego let's
try to figure out when the u.s. change
it was in La Jolla in San Diego like
2006 yeah well one was in La Jolla was
in San Diego yeah yeah I agree one was
in 2005 and then was in 2006 yeah La
Jolla was first that was nice yeah that
was that no it was nice yeah okay now
this is very sharp so you would assume
incorrectly that Nakamura would play
better than Fabiano because in sharp
positions Nakamura been Fabiano
however it's not true in this case
because unlike everybody in this room
and everybody at home and everybody in
and everybody else in the world
this is 99% preparation okay it's not
like boom what do I do here and I was
actually giving a lesson today it's a
none other than my cue ball
yeah Dani would be the same I'll tell
you the Danny's story next remind me
okay my comer
he showed me again he pled the
nimzo-indian and I moved for he's like
what do I do and I said well you
do this that you know like 12-bore Musa
theory and he's like what okay Danny
mature ky played a practice game with
yesterday I believe maybe two days ago
and I moved to he was out of his prep so
okay now at the very top level when you
play the most complicated theory kind of
opening either you get really lucky and
your phone doesn't know anything
which means you're dreaming or you got
to know a lot of prep in general
Nakamura's prep is very bad okay for a
top 10 player he's clearly the worst he
knows a lot and he doesn't understand it
it's like he memorized stuff and didn't
look at it deeply the opposite is true a
Fabiano Fabiano gets positions I moved
15 20 25 and he says the computer says
this but that's wrong I played like
several practice games and these are the
ideas it doesn't see okay and Nakamura
just tries to remember like what he did
and what the computer said which of
course he forgot against Wesley so and
lost and you would know that if you're
at my lecture earlier but you were busy
sleeping on the job now there's nobody
the Chess Club is kokomo in charge okay
what's that yeah I'm kidding
yeah Pokemon charge let's be interesting
okay so a three was played confusing the
audience can actually two no one opening
sometimes you can steal the ideas and
then you know another opening and
actually this idea of Queen B six and A
three if you've watched every lecture
I've given I played a game with math you
used to work at the club
scholastic no not Matthew Larson Matt
Barrett and Matt Barrett I had a queen
on b6 and I thought he was going to play
a three so I couldn't play Queen B - and
he didn't do that and he was like what
okay so and also from the exchange Slav
this idea is well known
the idea is after Queen takes B - the
Queen can't go to be four so Knight a
four is very annoying because your
Queens trapped so the point of a3 is
there's no Queen takes B - there's no
Queen B 4 there's no Bishop takes b4
later this should be fortunate and if
you're Anand you can play b4 and lose I
mean
because you're playing giri what's that
so I think the Queen's I'm b6 and it
stays there forever when the bishops on
g5 when the bishops on h4 then this
happens and you're like why did I play
Queen b6 he's not AC likes my answer
which is wrong but I tried and trying is
the first step to failure the lesson is
never try see there's a going to pays
attention and what happened the last
time you tried yeah exactly
okay good job and we could ask Ben Simon
for a lecture on that hi so Bishop e7
he's like I tried to get all the Trump
references out but I missed that one all
right and Bishop f2 like I said okay
Queen c7 Queen f3 and everybody
checkmates everybody so the audience is
happy now when I worked a long time ago
with Gregory CAI done of we did some
funny database analysis we would look at
a position like this one and then we not
this one but like this one and then when
there would be like 130 games and then
he would be like no no no we don't look
at those games ok it was based on rating
ok for him it was 2500
if either players were 2500 we're not
looking at that so when we can't look at
my games ok yeah he's like no no those
guys can't play I don't one of those
games ok so usually when there's the top
level games like this and they talk to
the players they quote other top level
games and they're like oh yeah this is
the game Rufus versus doofus ok and
while those are top players ok and
actually both players were following a
game that was played earlier which even
I knew that doesn't make any sense does
anybody know what game they were
following because they played all these
moves really quickly because they were
following another super GM game anybody
yeah I was two really good players
it was onigiri white against mvl did you
know that ok and both players play badly
in that game and nvl gave him the
Smackdown it's the only game gear he's
ever lost
although Geary would have been winning
by force but instead he lost then that
was analyzed analyzed analyzed analyzed
and they had all the improvements ready
so they played the improvements quickly
ok confusing the odd
they're like what are they playing so
quickly for okay all this has been
played before and in this position it
was something like rook g8 was played by
MVL and then I think here he thought for
like half an hour and played a mistake I
think he played a rook g1 and then after
d5 he was like already worse okay then
that was analysed forever
and they found improvements for
everybody okay so b4 which nobody
understands okay supposedly it's very
important in some variations later but
nobody could figure it out then they
turned their engines on and waited
forever so even though b4 was never
played before this is what Fabiano
expected because the engine said it was
the best okay and I'll tell you a
reverse story which I've told before
but you guys don't look like your
memories too good okay I was playing
Darwin yang and I prepared a line for
two months not for him but just in case
somebody did it okay should I go back to
the beginning and start over okay
welcome to mastering the middle game
okay he just in time No okay I'm half
kidding all right there's a there's a
fine for showing up late it's okay the
yeah okay so against Darwin yang I had a
novelty ready like I move 17 or
something and when we got to the
position the move before the novelty he
already didn't know the addition so he
had a long think before my novelty he
played the right move
I played the novelty and he didn't see
he had nothing okay tobol Arase right
right Arjen
oh no that's right Tobler Rossum's right
and he didn't know what the main move
was or the not main move or anything so
it was lost on him and he lost the game
ok here is the opposite they play moves
that never been played before their
sights prepared for it forever because
they look at the games with computers
and they're ready for whatever the
computer moves are and I don't
understand before and nobody without a
computer understands before because you
take it ok but somehow the computer says
it's the best
why is it the best nobody knows okay
hope you learned a lot this class all
right 95 queen f4 this is all their prep
they're moving instantly Knight g4
Bishop g4 'if I've and in this position
the computer says Queen f6 Bishop f6
Knight d5 Queen da now the computer says
knight c6 you'll notice the Queen
doesn't have anywhere to go right and
both players blitz to this position
because this was their prep and after
night c6 the line goes Bishop takes g4
Knight takes da this ship takes da and
White is slightly better and materials
equal confusing the crowd okay and this
was what the computer said which I'm
sure Nakamura had on his computer and
when your computer says play knight c6
winning the Queen usually you don't
challenge that like yeah 96 bends the
Queen yeah I agree with that and
Nakamura thought he would probably draw
that endgame with his two bishops and
Nakamura in his coach had already played
a practice game with the move Knight f5
which the computer said was nothing and
Fabiano said after looking at it for
like four minutes he thought I was just
winning computer just says equal but he
says well black can't move so if your
Pony can't move that's bad you can write
that down oh wait not moving is bad and
the computer says what black has to play
Bishop takes f5 here and and Fabiano's
like takes f5 I take with the bishop and
black can't move and whites just winning
there although I don't know if I agree
with that I think I'd rather have white
because I like what my opponent can move
that seems nice and white has a lot of
threats Bishop b6 is annoying I'm able
to do about Bishop d6 you on White has
all the trumps okay because we have a
knight on f5 f5 that's D 5 D 5 and F 5
it's never happened in the history of
the Sicilian okay when you're white in
the Sicilian and you
nine-time d5 and f5 both all black
pieces are misplaced
they should be on some other chess board
okay this should be six is annoying d6
is weak White's King is perfectly safe
black has no safe place for his King so
white has everything and black has a
queen now as I pointed out during the
tournament Hikaru was a queen up in
three games usually in super Grandmaster
tournaments with average rating 2780
you're not up a queen every game not
usually okay he was up a queen against
the nan for Rickon apiece and he won he
was up between this game for two pieces
and he lost and he was up a queen
against against two else might help me
out you guys followed the tournament now
you got nothing Arjen hmm maybe Oh were
you guessing you knew oh that doesn't
help me all right well you at home no
now you don't know you just looking it
up okay so white has all the trumps so
of course he won it was surprising down
a queen but Trump won all right
so rook to b8 that stops Bishop b6 that
was my main threat darn okay Knight f6
and now in this position White has a
very nice forced win but since
everything wins he didn't care he wasn't
like oh no I missed the forced win the
people on the internet like he didn't
play the forced win
rar okay he played rib d6 and the
computers were shouting for Knight takes
d6 okay I'm not sure our computers were
shouting okay and basically there's all
kinds of really tricky checkmates that's
why I liked all of this stuff for
example if King e7 the computer was
playing Bishop c5 man that doesn't look
very safe now does it it's a little safe
but not too safe and the checkmate
that's everybody's missing in the class
is the obvious move anyone come on you
probably the live broadcast they told
you what to do now you forgot
that would be knife f5 yeah does anybody
think he's right the guy who lectured
last you read his lecture you should
know ok anybody you're two-thirds
correct they're like let's see Knight f7
and Knight d5 or we don't get it okay so
Knight b5 obviously and the idea is
you're in check if King e6 I have
actually well that's the same eight so
King e6 or King EA 97 is made or you
could play rib d6 check if you're me and
after King e6 but that's mean
okay and after King FA there's a
different mate if I knew what it was I
tell you I'm sold
it's something to somewhere oh actually
this ship f5 is the move that is very
strong and then you play Bishop c5 and
rogue g1 and black resigns
I think it's Bishop f5 probably gonna
see this should have five because who
would okay so Rick d6 is also good
nothing wrong with that and now the
commentators were confused because in
this position after the move h5 black
did something that looked really stupid
but it actually wasn't a stupid at all
but you know one of the commentators now
he played Queen g5 check and after
Bishop e3 you can't take the bishop
because of Knight h6 check and so he
played Queen back to f6 and you're like
well wait a minute he played Queen g5
Queen f6 and whites just gained two
Tempe so that looks dumb however Hikaru
knew that was going to happen he didn't
think he was going to play Queens a g4
missed 9 h6 Hikaru was wondering what he
was going to against Bishop h4 the
computer says all Queen a chain ok
humans don't play Queen eh-eh that's not
how we roll so when he saw Bishop h4
Queen AJ he said well I'm not doing that
so I got to do something else okay and
if you're not going to do that that
you're going to play Queen g5 check in
Queen f6 so it wasn't like he blundered
and didn't see Queen g4 was losing he
just didn't want to allow Bishop h4
Queen h8
that's just terrible for black okay so
he did this that's reasonable okay nine
age six check this ship f5 which was
very nice move again black can't move
anything okay it's a terrible position
for black white has a past H pawn why
does attack on the king the bishop on e6
is pinned black sting is permanently
under attack and black can move anything
Queen e7 and now he thought a very long
time and he played the movie five and
the commentators and the people on the
internet who know everything they are
like oh he missed the computer move
Knight s7 and after the game Fabiana
showed the analysis of Knight s7 he was
looking at during the game and at the
end of the analysis about move six or
seven he missed like a strong move so he
analyzed Knight f7 but he didn't like it
as much as b5 and b5 is also winning now
b5 was just to get Hikaru back because
the cargo played b4 nobody understood it
so he played b5 and nobody understood it
that's fair okay and the idea is
obviously we'd like to keep pushing our
pawn or taking if the rook takes were
weakening the back rank and if the pawn
takes were blocking the B file and black
has no counter play and cacao wants
counter play and he may know if it loses
very quickly based on a miscalculation
Queen EA he wants the B file open so he
can use his Queen and rook and get the B
file to his advantage and if the B pawn
moves he could play Queen a4 and try to
get some counter-attack against the
white king obviously the Queen on e7
isn't really dangerous to this King here
and what's funny is after Queen e8
Knight f7 is even stronger
okay so Fabiano's move worked out better
than the actual best move and the idea
is we're getting checkmated and if
you're taking notes which he is getting
checkmated is bad it's not good so well
you're in check and you can't move your
king because your bishop on e6 is
hanging and Hikaru saw this and took
with the rook he was actually expecting
this bob was taking with the bishop
is you're letting the rook on the sixth
reign go over here okay and we have
another look that's going here and we
got bishops that are going here so that
that's bad yeah that's called getting
checkmated so rook h6 check rook g1
shack and you can see blacks positions
not very good right Arjun yeah so a
possible end of the game could be this
that's one possible end okay so after
Knight f7 he took rook takes and he
immediately played Queen b5 and I mean
Alok school were threatening Queen B -
we took upon and if white doesn't have
mate it's pretty good on for type 2 rook
h6 Hikaru is like oh that line that I
looked at doesn't work okay so he
resigned here obviously you have to move
your king somewhere doesn't matter where
and the rook checks and the rook checks
King here and let's see we take he takes
we play Bishop c5 check if you play King
f6 this looks good for white right and
if you play King to the back rank Rick
g8 check looks good for Wyatt okay now
of course it doesn't matter what you do
in this position you can play rook takes
Queen and win in fact the computer might
play rook takes Queen or if you want to
BQ you can do this most of you don't
look too cute maybe Arjen but the rest
of you okay so in this position after
rook h6 check he was like oh I'm losing
everything and you're taking notes
losing everything's bad okay now
actually those games were both lost for
the same reason okay preparation in the
first game where he lost to Wesley he
fought all in 92 that's my prep but it
was different position okay if he played
Bishop d3 White's slightly better and
this game he's looking like here's my
prep and black is okay and instead of 96
Fabiana i'll prepare them by playing
Knight f5 then there was a 30-minute
thing then there were more 30 minutes
and he's like man this game is not good
okay and then on Twitter the next day
he's like I'd absolutely crushed it was
destroyed okay and that happens in the
Sicilian when things work out looks good
when they don't work out
it looks like seve and Feingold which I
forgot because I got a lot of hypnosis
so I don't even remember that game I
think I won that game yeah that's my
recollection okay in the Sicilian that's
what we like to see because we see a lot
of both sides getting checkmated
sometimes at the same time and
unfortunately in this tournament for
Knight Wharf players the night herb
didn't do well later in the tournament
I believe the net very next round hikaru
played the same opening against MVL they
played the same first eight or nine
moves and Envia also got crushed okay no
more Berlin why draw one you can lose
right okay Geary should think like that
now to end the year this is a true story
so Arjuna like it on Twitter yesterday
Geary wrote this is true this isn't a
joke if it is a joke but it's true I'm
not making it up here he wrote New
Year's resolution tweet less win more
okay
very suspicious I don't think he can do
either one yeah
you're not going to do either one and
circle a car Aachen got him good was the
car yeah kind of Reggie blog I think was
khari Aachen
think so he said they should name unease
Geary the world champion of draws and
the truth hurts
now I noted that Kramnik drew his last
eight games and nobody mentioned that
and they were like yeah but Geary joined
14 draws in the candidates so too bad a
lot of people can draw they want its
Geary when he draws we get mad at them
and Gary's not playing boring when he
draws he has a lot of crazy games you
was some crazy comment he did 9 draws
solid and Kramnik 8 draws Cara wanna 7
draws Wesley so six draws also anon six
draws and I think Michael item six draws
and so now this is an exciting
tournament it was but somehow all the
games were drawing
[Music]
you
[Music]